Hi, I'm really excited to meet you.
I saw in your daughter's blog that she has a gluten allergy...
...so I got these gluten-free cookies. I hope she likes them.
I'm a crazy stalker.
Don't let me into your life.
I'm sorry, I didn't bring any copies of my resume with me.
I actually care so little about this job...
...I didn't even bother to print something out.
Sorry I'm late, dude. Traffic.
I just don't care about your time.
What kind of medical insurance do you provide?
I have cholera and I want you to pay for it.
What's your vacation policy like?
I can't wait to not be at my new job.
Do you think I'll get an office?
I want all the things I don't deserve.
I really want this job.
I'm the most desperate person you've ever met..
...and I'm like five seconds away from grabbing your hand and begging.
I'm a team player and I'm a people person.
All I have to offer you are cliches.
I'm not really looking right now but I would consider taking it...
...if the price is right.
Yeah, I'm gonna start looking for a job from my desk...
...the second you hire me.
Do you know anyone, actually?